the election of the Member of Parliament
the Volt and West I'm Albert us quickly
in the action returning of the cert the
above election do hereby give notice
that the number of votes recorded so
each candidate at the said election is
as follows Forrest Rebecca an Liberal
Democrats 1485 Green Christopher James
the Conservative Party candidate twenty
four thousand four hundred and fifty
nine hilling Julianne Doris Labour Party
twenty three thousand
20 3523
teague Martin of the UK Independence
Party 1587 the number of ballot papers
rejected was as follows
one to beneficial Mar 23
the more candidates than boat was
entitled to 14 big unmarked or wholly
void from certainty 44 and the total
votes 51,000 135 and I do hereby declare
that Christopher deaf James green is
Julie elected as Member of Parliament
for Bolton West
[Applause]
absolutely incredible an incredible
campaign an incredible experience
right across Bolton West we always seem
to deliver the most exciting results
it's been a hard-fought campaign and
this is such a fantastic demonstration
of democracy Britain to be so proud of
the other candidates fought so hard
their campaign teams fought so well I'm
delighted after having served ball from
West for two years to again serve the
constituents every single constituent in
Bolton West for the forthcoming
Parliament I would like to thank the
returning officer I like to thank all
the staff all the team here who made
this event this election possible in
Bolton West in the whole of Bolton and
also a representative the Wigan borough
as we'll also everyone in the Wigan
Barra the work they do in delivering
such a fantastic general election I'd
also like to thank the police we know
what's been going on recently it's
incredible what they do and I'm serve
you sure - we're all so creative or the
work that these do for us day in day out
I'd like to finish with thanking all of
my supporters my friends my family it's
been absolutely incredible over last few
weeks over the last two years and before
that so I'd like to thank them from the
bottom of my heart I couldn't ask for a
better team and also I would most like
to thank my agent Toby Hewitt who
[Applause]